We ask very simple questions:
What makes you happy?
What do you eat?
What do you like to cook?
And everywhere in the world we go and ask these very simple questions,...
...we tend to get some really astonishing answers.
It's hard to imagine he's gone.
Hard to imagine he's not just off on some faraway journey,
Hard  to imagine he'll not soon return with new stories to tell,...
...new foods to share.
Food is the entryway.
I'm a guy who spent 30 years cooking food professionally.
That's where I come from,...
...that's how I'm always gonna look at the world,...
...but food isn't everything.
And something comes up,...
...I'm happy to get up from the meal and wander off elsewhere.
Anthony Bourdain saw the world and experienced life in a way most people never will.
In places near and far, he talked, he tasted,...
...with open mouth and eyes and open heart and mind.
It's impossible from the outside to ever fully know...
...what goes on in someone else's heart or in their head.
It's impossible to fathom how quickly one's life can change.
Anthony once wrote,...
As you move through this life and this world, you change things slightly.
You leave marks behind however small.
And in return, life and travel leaves marks on you.
Most of the time, those marks on your body or your heart are beautiful.
Often, though, they hurt.
Anthony Bourdain was 61 years old.